bonsoir guillemin alors vous avez donc
des précisions aujourd'hui suite aux
annonces du président de la république
perd soir eh bien oui tout à fait
stéphanie parce que comme vous l'avez
dit les membres du gouvernement font la
tournée des plateaux depuis hier soir
c'est la pédagogie de l'exécutif en
actions à commencer par gabriela talent
le porte parole du gouvernement était ce
matin sur le plateau d'europe 1 avant de
venir présenter un compte rendu du
conseil des ministres à 13h un compte
rendu qui a commencé par un point sur la
situation sanitaire écouter la quatrième
vague pourrait avoir commencé
ce n'est plus un risque c'est une
réalité l'épidémie reprend dans notre
pays elle reprend vite et c'est pourquoi
nous prenons des décisions
supplémentaires dès à présent nous
agissons vite pour prendre l'épidémie de
cours nous agissons tôt pour que cette
vague nous submerge pas au niveau
national le taux d'incidence accélère sa
remontée en une semaine il a progressé
de plus de 60% et il s'approche du seuil
d alerte et ce sont bien ces chiffres
qui sont à l'origine des nouvelles
mesures annoncées hier soir par emmanuel
macron parmi ces mesures bien évidemment
ce fameux pass sanitaire mais également
donc la vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants mais pas pour l'ensemble de la
population comme la
annoncée gabriela talent l'exécutif mise
davantage sur l'incitation écouter
concernant la population générale
maintenant l'heure n'est pas à
l'obligation vaccinale mais à
l'incitation maximale le vaccin c'est ce
qui nous permet de vivre le plus
normalement possible
nous ne pouvons pas nous en passer nous
refusons de fermer à nouveau commerces
et restaurants parce que certains ne se
serait pas fait vacciner
oui il y aura une prime au civisme oui
les mesures de restriction mettront
désormais davantage sur les non vaccinés
que sur les vacciner nous l'assumons a
franchement car sortir du coc vide est
un effort collectif
alors cette menace du pass sanitaire
elle semble avoir eu déjà un effet
notable puisque selon le porte parole du
gouvernement
il y a eu déjà 1,5 million de rendez
vous pris sur la plateforme d'octo libre
depuis l'annnonce des mesures par
emmanuel macron humains gabriela talent
qui a parlé de souplesse tout de même
pour certains français
et oui tout à fait important le
gouvernement donc il ya annoncé qu'une
certaine souplesse seraient respectés
serait observée notamment à l'égard des
plus jeunes à l'égard des mineurs de
plus de 12 ans tout simplement je cite
pour qu'ils ne vivent pas un été
infernal autre annonce le gouvernement
devrait renforcer sa campagne de
vaccination à l'égard des seniors qui ne
sont pas encore vaccinés autre précision
plusieurs pays vous l'avais déjà dit
stéphanie ont été ajoutés à la liste
rouge dont la tunisie cela signifie
notamment que les voyageurs en
provenance de ces pays devront respecter
un isolement d'une dizaine de jours et
enfin
gabriel attal a confirmé que le régime
transitoire de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui devait prendre fin le 30
septembre sera bien prolonger jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2021 merci gaymard aussi
donc en direct de l'elysée